- Va me programmer
de la norépinéphrine.
- Tout juste arrivées
de Franceseses infirmières
sont en formation. Elles ont
fait le saut, malgré la crise
qui sévit au Québec.
ROMANE DESCAMPS, infirmière
clinnnnnnne installée au Québec
- Effrayée un petit peu, mais
après, en France, c'est pareil.
Au final, les infirmières sont
sous pression, les hôpitaux
ntntnt sous pression.
- La chose peut paraître
étonnante, mais en Europe,
la pratique infirmière
au Québec aurait encore
une image très favorable.
INDIANA BELAIR, infirmière
clinicienne installée au Québec
- On parle beaucoup de
la pratique ici et ça a
encore une très bonne image.
Il y a des groupes avec
des milliers de personnes
qui parlent tous les jours,
qui demandent des conseils
pour venir vivre ici.
- Tant mieux parce que
ces étrangères sont devenues
essentielles.
Pour les infirmières, depuis
cinq ans, la proportion
des diplômés hors Québec a
doublé. En 2017, ça représentait
11 % du total; l'an passé,
on avait atteint 22 %.
Le réseau québécois est
maintenant devenu dépendant
de ces professionnels venus
d'ailleurs.
- Parce que les besoins
sont trop importants, puis
c'est vraiment une main-d'oeuvre
qu'on ne peut plus se passer.
- Cette année, la moitié
des nouveaux employés du CIUSS
du Nord-de-l'Île-de-Montréal
seront recrutés à l'étranger;
des infirmières, mais aussi
des technologues et
des travailleurs soc
FLORENT VERJUS, Bureau recrut.,
CIUSSS du Nord-de-l'Île-de-Mtl
- On a vraiment un objectif
d'embaucher au moins
250 ressources étrangères
rien que l'année prochaine.
Mais, quand je dis ressources,
c'est des travailleurs sociaux,
des infirmiers...
- Pour y arriver, le CIUSSS du
Nord-de-l'Île-de-Montréal crée
son propre bureau d'immigration,
qui compte cinq employés.
- On s'est dit : il faut créer
un bureau du recrutement pour
vraiment les intégrer,
les suivre dans leur cheminement
d'immigration.
- Si je vous dis CHSLD, CLSC,
est-ce que ça vous dit
quelque chose?
- En plus de la formation
pratique, il y a la théorie
sur le fonctionnement du réseau
québécois et ses acronymes,
souvent complexes.
Mais, on offre aussi
de l'accompagnement pour les
écoles, ou encore le logement.
NICOLE DESCHAMPS, recrutement
CIUSSS du Nord-de-l'Île-de-Mtl
- De s'assurer aussi, quand
ils sont ici, qu'ils sont
bien intégrés, bien adaptés,
qu'ils ont vraiment le soutien
nécessaire.
- Parce que tout n'est pas rose,
ces infirmières découvrent
rapi i i i i i irritants locaux.
AUDREY GRESSIER,
infirmière clinicienne
- Ici, les médecins de famille,
on n'en a pas tout de suite.
Aller à l'urgence, il faut
attendre très longtemps.
- L'accès aux médecins, ça reste
une chose, moi, je trouve,esese,
très compliquée. Ça m'a un peu
heurtée par rapport à la France.
- Toutes les régions du Québec
sont engagées dans une cou
au talent à l'étranger.
Le CIUSSS du Nord-de-l'Île-de-
Montréal espère être en tête.
- Est-ce qu'il va y avoir
de la concurrence? Peut-être.
Je pense qu'il ne faut pas
qu'on se le cache, par rapport
à l'évaluation des dossiers,